clifford le gros chien rouge est vraiment gros
rouge et
new york
l'histoire suit essentiellement emily
elizabeth emily trouve ce chien
et le monde entier se retourne
il est comme un gros énorme chiot géant
rouge vif c'est gentil ce que nous voulions garder
des livres est le  sens que
clifford représentait l'amour inconditionnel
emily et clifford sont si adaptés l'un à l'
autre parce qu'elle ferait n'importe quoi
pour son chien et son chien ferait n'importe
quoi pour elle
c'est ce qui rend cela si spécial
il essaie toujours d'apporter l'amour et l'
amitié dans la vie de n'importe qui
juste en regardant  lui fond ton coeur
[Musique]
est l'un de ces grands films familiaux
le genre de film dont les gens se
souviennent longtemps
j'ai hâte de voir ça sur grand
écran regarde-le
il est si mignon clifford clifford clifford
clifford
[Musique]
vous